been Communist China during the Cultural
Revolution in the 1960s and 70s during
this hour and 15-minute event from
Pomona College in claremont california
she's joined by her daughter for a dance
routine and dramatic performance good
evening thank you for coming my name is
Lori de Roche and I'm the president of
Pomona's Associated Students tonight's
presentation is generously sponsored by
the public events committee and the
ASPCA speaker series I would also like
to thank Matt Goldstein our
communications commissioner for
organizing this event tonight's speaker
is an acclaimed memoirist and novelist
among the first generation born and
raised in Mao's China on she men served
as the leader as a leader of the Little
Red Guards and was eventually sent to a
labor camp with thousands of other
students her party involvement
eventually inspired her to audition for
one of the many films made by mouths
wife who reigned as Orchestrator of the
Cultural Revolution after the death of
Mao and Minh subsequent announcement she
emigrated to the United States in 1984
at the time of her arrival she spoke no
English but within ten years she had
written a best-selling memoir and a
novel in her adopted language her
writing has been praised for its raw
sharp language and historical accuracy
her memoir rhetta's alia tells the story
of her childhood in communist China and
has compared been compared to the Diary
of Anne Frank she has also written for
works of historical fiction Katharine
becoming Madame Mao wild ginger and
Empress orchid following her
presentation we'll have a question and
answer section session there's a mic on
either side of the stage though you go
you can ask your questions and those and
then c-span can hear your questions
please join me in welcoming to Pomona
College on Chi Minh
thank you
I'm so glad to be here it's it's
exciting to see the different color of
hair and ski and the clothes I will
never forget the first time I I arrived
in America I was shocked in occasion
like this and I'm coming to your face to
face and I always remind me the first
moment it was September 1st 1984 I
landed in America and I tried to my
suitcases coming out and I had a urge to
pee because I did not know that I would
be able to pass the custom cuz I knew I
didn't speak English and am I here on
college visa and it was in the American
Airport toner room I discovered that the
toilet paper was free and all I brought
with me was a suitcase filled with
pretty much nothing but toilet papers
and it scratches and I remember I was
holding my passport and follow the crowd
and was shocked and seeing this
different color of skin and hair and
eyes and follow and they went through
the waiting in the line the custom and I
was determined that to try and all I
knew was to word thank you so when I
presented my passport and the
immigration officer took it and he
smiled and he said now you know what
basically yeah
oh you're here for college welcome but
in my ear I heard Lulu's a little look
and I say thank you and he look at me up
and down a little again and I say thank
you and then his face go along and he
says no and I say thank you and then he
goes do you know that room that where
people get interrogated and they get
deported and the I was sitting in that
room and broke down first time in my
life I was such a hardcore communist and
in here I knew I was about to be
deported because I live my way here and
I can't recall how long exactly I sit in
that room and you talk about flashbacks
and everything rushes back to my mind
and today I think about it I think that
was what made me who I am
I lived in China for 27 years and I grew
up with mouse teaching and madame au s--
revolutionary operas and today after all
these years if I close my eyes I can
still remember the moment I leave my
entire school in my elementary school
years that every morning we go through
the mouth little red quotation book
first page first paragraph
Chairman Mao teaches us Linda Amma she
the crazy liliane Chatel vocal tandem
traditionally loyalty to Jamarcus
leniently everybody chanted
I would say that I had a pretty happy
childhood because I was from a middle
upper class family my my parents are
both teachers and we didn't starve the
very first memory was that my mother was
talking to my younger sisters nanny now
both parents met they they work so they
only remember my mother picked me up
from the Union kindergarten ten o'clock
in the evening and the and the teacher
always says threatens me says you know
if your mother don't come to pick you up
and I'm going to leave you here we were
standing outside the kindergarten he
said I had my four kids to attend I
can't stay with you every night and I at
that moment I was always saw my mother
appear under the streetlight walking
toward me I remember that conversation
my mother had with my younger sister
nanny and she asked her why my
daughter's two years old that she can't
stand what have you been feeding her and
the nanny confessed that she's been
feeding her water only my mother says
where where the coupons I gave you to
buy food and rice and she said that she
sent back to her village and after a
while the country gets bad and we I
start to eating food from trash cans and
in the market and my mother couldn't
afford a nanny anymore and the nanny
sister it's okay I understand it doesn't
make any difference so she went back to
her village two month later we heard the
news that she poisoned her entire family
to end the starvation and she points her
herself - and I remember my mother was
regretted it's so bad and she couldn't
get over with it she thought that she
was responsible for it and in the
meantime we were fighting
Vietnam and we were told that children
America children in Vietnam they were
suffering they're starving
we were under the care of communist
party and although we were where we were
hungry but we are fighting for a cause
and we were fighting to rescue children
America and then we know that America
was the source of evil because all these
movies that that we were presented in
the children theater I remember was my
first movie that US Marine carved spook
puffed out of Vietnam via cone informant
a girl my age and we'll remember on the
screen you have that she had her eye
bandage over her eyes
and we presented that movie twice and
every time when we I see that movie all
the ghosts scream and went under the
seat until the boys is okay okay it's
over so we had a hatred a mouse's man of
humanity will refuse to preserve his
life and the expenses of that humanity
our relationship with Vietnam it's like
the gone to teeth Veon ant was built the
gum when the gums gone can't eat
survived so whole nation was mobilized
and we're making underground bomb
shelter the family assigned to make a
bricks
we just get all the third all the soil
and in the whole neighborhood was a
brick factory and our family was
assigned to make 200 bricks a week and
we just can't do it
my mother had tuberculosis and I
remember her happy at the moment she
come home so
happy she says she was wearing this mask
she says I'm so happy that my unit my
work unit send me back they say I'm
contagious so now I can finally come
home and be with my children so she will
run around the house wearing this big
mat and then she she's just so happy and
we're so happy to be with my mother and
then because I was eating out of trash
cans and all the children the entire
neighbourhood the school
we got infected with tapeworms you know
my grandmother coming from the village
and come a basket book of garlics we
just ate raw garlic's and in the go-to
party and it comes out but after a while
the whole tummy was cumin hold it and I
was at the school one day the next day
my table mate didn't show up and the
next day a teacher announced it that she
died because the tapeworm went through
her appendix and it became so bad that
the the government gave each parents a
pill
it's called pagoda pills so we were
actually we were no I was eager to take
that pill because it's sweet we would
know candy it's like a like a sweet
candy in the shape of a pagoda and it's
colorful so I ate a lot of them and the
next day I went to the school the
medicine took it's a fact then that
filth the itch in my rear end and the
tapeworm tried to tiger came out from
the rear and and also come from that
from the front so you look at each other
and eventually be so bad I had to reach
out and pull it out and then put it out
in the middle of the class and the
throat underneath and try to throw it as
far as I could and it stinks and I had
to say it's not mine now my paper worm
in the meantime we were busy and the
mall says yet Americans are taking over
again now China is going to be the next
we show a more and more picture of US
Marine killing the vehicons
we're so terrified the school calls him
like 2 o'clock in the morning in Goa and
they're just practicing combat and I was
selected as one of the best to be
trained at the Shanghai garrison so when
I learned the lesson I could come I
bring I teach my school school makes how
to defend ourselves and in the Shanghai
garrison we were we had an instructor at
the army instructor and we were had to
we had to get up 5 o'clock in the
morning in the winter and we're practice
with a wooden stick first and then the
guns so we always remember that we line
up and then we have to do it in the dock
take the gun out and put it back also we
have to be packing three minutes ready
to go and we told her over and over
again and it will also to practice any
we have bricks and they're armed and the
harder to gain the arm strength to hold
the target in our target was it is a
dummy straw made of straw and on top of
the me there is a US soldiers helmet so
every morning the whistles comes and get
up here they okay and then we were
practicing poking holding our goals
three hours go sha sha sha sha in a
either in my team and we see during the
day we see the war movies and then and I
I just hear myself and the instructor
always yell than me I'm Jimmy
you've never seen the enemy I don't see
enemy in your eyes and the way you do it
you you don't you're not doing the right
he was shy and collect this you have to
do this and you see his intestine fall
out cuz the US soldier he's taller
bigger if you don't do this to him he is
going to do that to you
imagine your intestines falls off and
today 20 years 30 years later I'm
happily married to a former US Marine a
Vietnam veteran and I our wedding night
he said I hope I don't have flashbacks
and I said I hope I don't have
flashbacks
you know this Vietnam veterans these
people with their knives under the bed
bed bed guns he was afraid he put a gun
here and he put his bullets other place
and eventually he removed this he
figured I would be the one to use it
more likely but anyway I was happy that
I have this mission and when I ride have
become a madam all of that period that I
lived through I remembered
the songs the okras that she make us
feel that's it's it's beautiful and it's
basically it's Madame Mao self portrait
I'm gonna read one paragraph so you get
an idea by the way Madame Mao was some
sentenced in 1991 she
may 14th she hang herself by suicide and
become a Madame Mao I am did this it is
paragraph I'm illustrating illustrating
how she was a from eighth early feminist
turn it into a mass murderer I was
interested how that she made that
transition and at four years old she had
a bounce bounce feet her mother come to
bound her and how this how she does this
emotional journey that she went through
and I did a lot of research on how she
grew up because I think in it's it's so
American and I think it's good that
Americans when you do research we put a
lot of energy on study this person's
former formative years and in Chinese
history all these important figures you
never learned how they grow up and I
think that's a that's missing you for
example Manimal many books on her never
talk about her childhood Empress orchid
sushi who ruled China for fifty years
never talk about the years before she
was sent
17 years old it became the country the
Emperor's concubine
so always after that but I found it's so
important and how she grew up and like I
just told you how my childhood did to me
for example the Empress in my research I
found that in her teenage years her
village friends peasants have to eat
first one for dinner and a parent
parents have to sell their children to
pay off debt okay how can that not
affect this person person's entire
future way of thinking
the girl is never able to forget the
pain even when she became Madame Mao the
most powerful woman in China during the
late 60s and 70s she recalls the pain as
evidence of the crime of feudalism and
she expresses her outrage in a series of
operas and ballets the woman of the red
detachment among many others she makes
them billion population share her pain
to understand the pain is to understand
what the plot Aryan went through during
the old society she cries at a public
rally it is to understand the necessity
of communism she believes the pain she
suffered gives her the right to lead the
nation it is the kind of pain that shoot
through your core she tears the actress
you can't land on your toes and you
can't fly either
you're trapped ting down there is an
invisible soul you're tolis the breath
dies out the whole house hears you but
hears no rescue I to prepare this I am
going to get present to you a little a
minute Polly the woman of red attachment
and my partner Lorien is trained by the
Miss Lee the choreographer who designed
who worked for madam Mao and designed
the original ballet of woman of rare
detachment and Madame I worked on this
for 10 years since 1960s all the way and
she seems to be so obsessed with this
piece because it's a self-portrait of a
slave got beaten just like her childhood
running away and you have to remember
that during the Cultural Revolution from
1976 1964 all the way to
seventy-six and our mission basically
allowed to watch nothing but this
brainwashing operas and she watched
sheshe tree she she does it with
seduction in art and she says it's never
enough or too much to to make to
perfection - perfect
visit ballet in ten years so she worked
on the every move from my interviews all
the leading actress and the
choreographer misleading and and I know
especially metamer loves this hatred
I'll never forget the hatred and an
enemy and it's hers that the spirit she
wants the girls China and to - to
remember that you are as we were told
that they will as females that we were
born it's grass born to be stepped on
and she wanted to fight that and we
really believe in that and embraced the
concept we love the Opera House in the
ballet because only in the operon
ballets we get to escape the life that
we were living in only in this ballet
that we lived a life of hero and the
hero ins Joe music please
and the music was Audrey original also
designed by Madame Mao
thank you so you imagine I was on the
stay of Martin Delany all these millions
of Chinese girls calling this anaconda
agent um American imperialism liberate
them starving children and when I was 17
years old
I was one of 1/3 of Chinese who are sent
to the countryside the labor camps it's
a big migration I think it because the
Red Guards and then it's out of the
hands now can't control cos we were
starving was going getting worse so we
were told that we gotta kind of grow our
own rice and it was in the labor camp I
found out that my believe in communism
was wasn't really it was not a workable
idea and we were supposed to grow cotton
but the land in East China Sea where we
we try to produce cotton see grow only
this big because it's salted land and I
just can't and then we work in a very
poor condition where I I shared with
eight girls in the bunk no privacy all
the things that we were only space with
within the mosquito net and I wrote that
in red Italia I think that the physical
hardship it was easy to tolerant who are
young seventeen eighteen entire East
China Sea we had a 10 farms labor camps
and it's about a hundred thousand youth
aged from 16 to 25 and we carried manure
we do our own rice paddy and plant the
rice and you probably American think
about it sister
nice picture they're planning with a
straw hat and the planning
but then you don't think about the
mosquitoes the infested and also we
planned a feat in the infected water
with all that kind of fungus now feet in
the feet of all toes between toes all
cracks police when you soak that in the
manure in the pig [ __ ] and get a more
infection and then when they I had an
injured back and I was not allowed to
rest basically we had a no come out
whole year so that's why I love raining
today I still love it because the only
when the raining can't the ring comes
that we get to rest take a breath
I'm not talking about small ring it has
to be thick big poori
when the stress shoe floats that we
can't plant anymore and then one day my
back was injured was so bad and I was
went to the headquarter and the doctor
was so tired he opens five o'clock and
here the long line when it was my turn
he asked him to ask me to lay down and
he would not have time let me undress
he just had me lay down he applied the
acupuncture over my clothes for teeny
toes first time I was able to get up
right away and then after a few times
because I went back to work right away
after a few times I can only cry just
couldn't get up anymore and if he the
doctor was frustrated and he says I told
you to rest why don't you rest and I say
I wanna rest but I need your letter of
permission to give to my company leader
and he went quiet and I then I found out
he was only allowed to give three letter
permission and normally he used to say
that one for his boss secondly for
tractor driver who will bring him
thought and food and third he would save
it for the girl that he had his eyes on
so no letter of permission for the
patient talking about 100,000 youth in
this labor camp locked together and we
were not allowed to date the price of
date was a bullet so you think about how
the Communists how we were kept in a lot
normally this is what we do
we were patrol the the the hardcore
comrades like me we're giving a gun
we were patrol East China Sea around our
labor camp and we were told to catch the
Taiwanese spy who was swimming through
the the sea which never happened is
ridiculous but we were told that we go
patrol and try to catch them when we
catch suspicious people we check their
feet first
because if there's fishermen they always
claim themselves of fishermen if they're
fishermen their feet is going like this
the toast
spread out and if the feet look totally
look like this they were in leather
shoes but we never catch any spice when
we caught with our own comrades coupling
in the wheat fields there's always
people risk their life makes a great
subject for novels but in real life we
catch the couple we were become that the
party secretary were brainwashing the
girl until she will agree to say in
public on the trial that she was raped
as you know China were not tolerant any
rapists where were communist society
where crime free so the boy will be
dragged out as a laborer as a rapist and
the common company leader would say to
ask the crowd what do we do with the
rapists dad to latest
and everybody agrees that's rapists and
he's dragged out on the tractor and boom
and his family will receive a letter
charge for 26 cents for the bullet the
purpose was to kill a hare to shock the
monkeys
of course by accident I learned the
poetry of God that's how I put it when
you are not allowed to do human things
you do you find an alternative that
makes relatively a best-seller I guess
it's a extraordinary human existence and
I was lucky and unlucky to have it - had
an opportunity to escape because of my
plutonium look in 1976 nobody knows that
now was dying madam I was secretly
prepare herself to take over China's
leadership and she was using again the
propaganda the movie and to tomb to make
her way she was looking talent scouting
a face image to put in the movie on to
to present as a woman leader and I was
hoeing in a cotton field and I was
noticed and I remember they that day
clearly there was a clear day and I was
in the cotton field I was slow because
my my spinal cord had it would become a
distorted after the injury and all I can
remember was just just try it I want to
die because this is it it's it's
humiliating to not be able to get up and
to pay and to be fall behind all the
time and to be hated because you see
it's it easy to help anybody when when
you can lend a hand but when you were
working 18 hours a day
you just hate another comrade who has
you have to cover her work you wish her
death and it was that day a wide then
appear on Corazon and it come and star
about a hundred yard way and in the
labor camp we never see anything not
leave a tree and we or everybody stopped
and watching the van and I thought that
was my moment to catch up so I can't
have I can't have dinner in an austere
then walk out few people in long green
army coats and they came and scanned
scanned the people one by one and they
came in to me as my name my age and I
and asked me how to get to headquarters
and it was strange because they did the
kneeling down is like a metronym with
their with their eyes in a afterwards
after I gave the answer they they took
the opposite direction so the next day I
received a order that I was assigned to
go to Shanghai film studio to compete
for the role of Mary mouth movie and
that I was chosen because I had a no
knowledge no acting background because
there's a sign of a political
reliability that's most important to
Maremma that I was a piece of a white
paper that she can draw anything on it
and actually I was happy that I will
giving chance to escape the labor and I
found a lot of talent beautiful people
gather at the film studio and they know
how to cry how to smile and I had no
nothing
oh I knew was scene II Mademoiselle bruh
and I seen with big love voice and I was
chosen and I was taught a political
correct oklet area way of acting and
they did a some screen test
I remember they asked me to drink so I
was given a cup of empty they gave me a
cup of water and I was pretend drinking
and I was in the middle of drinking and
the instructor says stop economy see
your little pinky tilted up there's miss
blue Jersey the correct way to drink
water is to grab them up and gobble down
in one breath and wipe your mouth with
both of your sleeves and he was in the
middle of preparing all that we heard
them all died September 9th 1976 multi
and the October 8th met Emma and her
gang of four was arrested two months
later I was denounced as meta Mouse
political debris and was ordered back to
the labor camp and for the rest of the
eight years is a long struggle I try to
stay in Shanghai and became a temporary
worker although in my dozier I was I was
you know it's a new new generation of
leaders and powers they just I was
considered matter most people and in a
Chinese Way of punishing me is just to
work me and isolate me so I was never
allowed to go to school I never allowed
any promotion I was paid $3 a month and
I was sent to the hardest places to work
and I remember fainted under on the
floor during work all the time and I was
not allowed to go to the hospital and I
start coughing blood all that and I'm my
best friend at that time she her name is
Joan Chen you probably heard know her in
the movie of the last Empress Empress
she played the Empress and she was told
not to be my friends because I was
politically dangerous and then she went
to America I worked with a film director
Bertolucci
and she feel safe enough to wrote me a
letter
how are you and I told her that I was
and not doing too well I was thinking
about committing suicide and I said just
no difference you know and then she
wrote have you ever thought of America
and I I guess I didn't speak English
she said you're willing to work hard
like avoid three jobs and I said are you
kidding on the farm labor camp so she
says I will what can you do what do you
know and I say I can paint I do big
calligraphy Chinese Chinese painting
wall murals she says just do it and
she'll find me a article which is our
Institute of Chicago who sent me an i-20
and I I received and I did not know how
to fill out the forms because they um it
comes first Eliza name and I and I heard
from old people in the lane neighborhood
they say you go to America you have to
have American name enough so eventually
my name is Angie but it's not American
name and they say and she is close to
Andrew and to write Andrew so I I am
still in my I still because this
application form I was so afraid to ruin
it so I copied the entire thing and I
did not know in the back of the
insurance policies
I copied that too so I work on that
original the scratching paper and I I
still have it today and I my name is
angel min and the next thing was sex I'm
supposed to male female mock female but
I I check into the dictionary the
Communist English Chinese dictionary it
doesn't have a word for sex so I
couldn't go on and that
and so it became too difficult I
couldn't understand anything
so Joan says why don't you go to one of
my friend who was a Travel Guide in 1984
so I went to her two o'clock I went ten
o'clock after work I waited for four
hours
two o'clock she came home belly tired
she didn't wanna go through that and she
says okay just let me do it for you and
she said okay high school middle school
high school and an English language
skill poor average good excellent of
course excellent
and the next step was the passport and
because of my record bad record
political record and I was not allowed
to to apply but I worked so hard
eventually I take out the name of Joan
Chen and then they are I said I promise
I will be do my country good so the
party secretary says asked me he's the
type of person who don't know English
but pretending he knows and so he sees
America's begin with an aide and all he
knows about we know learn about English
about three countries Albania North
Korea and Russia and then he says he
asked me if there's any difference
between America and Albania and I say
there's no difference and then he says
are there polite Aryans in America I
said yes he said do you intend to
promote revolution America I said yes
so here stem I got my passport so the
next thing you know is to get a visa and
that's even harder than the passport
because today you have to be a PhD
candidate to get American visa and I was
coming here for a BFA and at that time
they already you know you have to be a
bastard candidate and I thought I was a
dead bird no longer afraid of boiling
water
so homage is gonna go try and I wrote
down myself introduction in Chinese and
I haven't had that travel guide friend
translated eventually I that day for
good luck I borrowed my mother's dress
and it was my mother's shirt and in a
skirt my mother said why do you want to
wear my old shirt and the ring is
already you know had a yellow yellowish
ring on it and I said mom just I'm so
nervous and just [ __ ] luck because I
already applied passport that means my
job at the film studio is already in
danger in China we call one care to win
Oh whence you you walk away somebody
else is gonna take that spot and I was
going to kill myself anyway so I said
mom just let me have it so I took my
mother's clothes went to the consulate
and I spent them if I was a lousy
actress in front of camera I presented a
Oscar quality performance in front of
American consulate or maybe not oh maybe
he knew I was a phony to begin with you
just decided to be so American and he
actually I can't remember the male of
female when my eye all I could think was
that I will not let the Consul General
interrupt me because if he or she did
she's gonna find out I don't speak
English so when my name was called I go
my name is Ahn Chi Minh I wanted to go
to America
like a scene in Opera and I got the
answer okay
I understood that word okay and then he
closed the window and passed me to the
next window and it was a Chinese
secretary and she gave me a say look huh
you think of your food Americans it's
just you're lucky
Americans like people with determination
so I was in that interrogation room and
stay the longest time in my life finally
a translator came to me and I broke down
and I said I did everything I could
Chuck please I'm begging you for an
opportunity I don't speak English I lied
and but if you give me three months I
will speak English if I don't I promise
you I would be poured myself and she
checked my paper locked me and Johnny
Tydings Allah you are too nervous and
she or he took me to the officer and and
then okay so they put me through
different airlines and airports and then
eventually I landed in front of the
foreign advisor at the Art Institute of
Chicago who pull out the draw and take
on my application form and was mad at me
since you don't understand a word of the
same but here on the application form
you see your age it's perfect and I
stare at the floor say thank you thank
you thank you
and so happy I got a chance and he says
you know what by policy you have to make
it I can't take you now you have to make
it back in within six months otherwise
schools are obligated to report
notify immigration which will resolve my
deportation but to me six months so I
start with Sesame Street and on after
that was mr. Rogers neighborhood I love
this guy because he was the only person
he speed the speed I couldn't understand
he was the first person and the one day
I was 27 years old and the far my subs
because I understood this man was saying
after you know I tie my shoes if I'm so
glad you're sitting over there just be
yourself the best gift you can give to
anybody is your honest self and here's
I'm crying because for 27 years I was
told that I was this school and bolted
on the communist tyranny machine and
after mr. Rogers neighborhood was Oprah
Winfrey and I study English and the you
know I feel close to that Oprah Winfrey
image because when I was doing sha with
the pictures we were presenting who are
our comments were African liberation
soldiers and many of them are females
and the ethnic American face is very
dear to me so I keep that channel and
learning the Oprah Winfrey and and
best-selling author and ten years later
I I made it so I don't really have an
American with express myself I'm I'm
happy so I'm going to send you this
opera that I was chosen on
it's called toast to victory and it's
Metta most favourite and in my favor
because it's like you your your Beatles
so you don't know anything else I didn't
know anything else and I think the the
words you probably don't even care to
know it's a propaganda but the tone is
that the music is the ancient Chinese
music it's our tradition in our way of
expressing victory and the happiness and
I brought my hat
so you'll see my favorite image with
community income to-20 rato super silly
engine
okay now I'm American author and I
wanted to just briefly tell you that I
feel free to choose what I wanted to
write and I feel this is my um repay to
this country who accepted me and I'm
still I'm not over to this that the
person hoped that the American to let me
in and give me the opportunity to live
and I want to UM this woman Empress
orchid sushi who Ruth China for 50 years
and there is some because a lot of
authors in China they're they can't say
what they think and and here I feel
privileged so I I think it's to
understand China's today and it's
important to stay to understand the era
of the opium war of the 13 country
invasion China and the history starting
her lifetime from 1860 all the way up to
1908 and I want to give you idea you
probably in your class in your in your
textbooks they probably never mentioned
this person and it's it's very normal
because this is the way you you get this
is by the author of China and the
Empress Dowager and annuals memories of
the court of peking in 1914 and the
biography named a Sir Edmund Backhouse
and I'm quoting him my intercourse with
sissies started in 1902 and continued to
until her death
I had a captain usually close record of
my secret association with the Empress
and others possessing notes and the
message is written to me by her majesty
but I had the misfortune to lose all
these manuscripts and papers
if you know the Forbidden City
anybody who traveled to China tell me if
this is a possible now I'm recording
another person who I'm very much respect
was American investigative historian
named as sterling Seagrave
he wrote this book called dragon lady
the life and legend of the last Empress
of China 1992 I'm quoting him now
in 1974 somewhat too awks first
embarrassment and to the private dismay
of China's scholars everywhere bad house
was revealed to be a counterfeiter the
comment had been exposed
but his counterfeit material was still
Bachrach scholarship anybody who study
Chinese your will cross this back that
this scholarship and this is by George
Morrison he who is a London child times
sorry London times China correspondent
from 19 from 1892 to 1912 times one of
the Asian states you see sages how do
you say s AG sage thank you one of the
ancient sage of China foretold that
China will be destroyed by a woman the
prophecy is approaching fulfillment it's
very much like the Chinese tradition
saying every downfall of Dynasty is a
fault of a concubine this is a very
typical and here's from a American envoy
to China 1898 the Empress has shown
herself to be benevolent and economical
her private character has been spotless
and the last one I'm just quoting the
Chinese textbook which was my textbook
imprint from 1949 all the way up to 1991
and this is official and today because
1991 I'm already here so I don't know
what's being taught over there exactly
now but I can guarantee you if you go to
18 go to the Forbidden City you will
hear the tour guy will tell you here's
how the Empress was mistreated abused by
the Empress Dowager who give the Emperor
rice ball and was filled with a grow
away with the mode on top of covering it
a my text book basically said one thing
she was a mastermind of pure evil and
intrigue so I wrote in Venezuela because
I feel that the official Cultural
Revolution history it's didn't tell my
story or Mis presented basically polenta
waterfalls history and Madame all same
thing and here I just wanted to find out
why this mastermind of murder
why and I found surprising results I'm
I'm going to read you the last paragraph
of my preload I'm using her first voice
of Her Majesty's voice confusion says
Confucianism has been shown to be flawed
China has being defeated I have received
the no respect no fairness no support
from the rest of the world a neighboring
allies watched us falling apart with
apathy and helplessness the insult for
me is not about this unbearable way of
dying but about the absence of honor in
our inability to see the truth it
surprises me that no one realizes that
our attitude toward the end is comical
in its absurdity during the last
audience I couldn't help about y'all I
am the only one who knows that my hair
is white and thing the court refused to
hear me my ministers saw the French die
in my finally arranged a hairstyle as
real knocking their heads on the ground
that they send heaven's grace
ten thousand years of health lonely
your majesty so I tried to be as
accurate as possible these books if you
chew them through and I think I will
give you a pretty good idea about about
history and to end my presentation I'm
going to present you a short play in the
reading action reading from chapter 9
and I think I did the extensive research
because I found that the some of the
things rolling history about how Empress
orchids sushi rise to power
it was so cheaply done they say oh she's
so pretty that she was what walk walking
in the garden Emperor just spotted her
and she was chosen from 3,000 beauty and
to be the favorite and I found that
there is a lot more to that in the books
of the eunuchs they they kept they had
the power of these poor young girls how
they have to bribe the eunuch to get
near to where they are so this girl
because she seventeen years from the
poorest province of China
she had a little bit width than others
that's how she I think if you look at
her wits and you think about how she
managed China and ruled China for 50
years and this give you a little bit
sense and the hint of her ability to
conduct to do the best she could and I
managed to stay not only get to power
and stay in power I am going to have a
good time because I get to play a bad
guy I'm gonna play the chief eunuch shim
okay
you have to bear with me I just put this
thing on one second
lady Yahoo Nala you need him to be so
formal as your slave shim does not
deserve such respect I don't mean to
criticize but you must be careful you
can't get both of us in trouble I am
desperate cheap shim please rise and
have a seat
I have a humble gift for you this is
this is His Majesty's the engagement
gift to you
it is an authenticated piece a pledge if
you don't know its value allow me to
explain
I am glad you recognized its value
however I would still like you to have
it
why do you own Allah why to tell you the
truth this is the last thing I own I
would like you to have it because I
understand the value of your health I
cannot accept it rise to Shem I dare not
I insist but later Yahoo Nana the ruie
will be more valuable when I become the
mother of Emperor's anthems child
thank you for helping me so uh which day
m'lady
would you like me to schedule your with
His Majesty does the date make a
difference big difference you would like
to see his Majesty on your most fertile
days don't you that's right
the date is the 14th day of the next
full moon perfect how a mark that they
in my book right away if you don't hear
from me
we're set you'll be summoned 14th day of
next full moon until then milady
wait chief Shem please bear with my
questions what if his Majesty wants to
see another lady on that day how can you
make him want me instead don't worry my
lady I have a way to win in the
Forbidden City and that is to say and
that is to say yes his majesty expresses
the desire to see any other ladies that
day
for example lady Lee I say I'm sorry
Your Majesty lady Lee is unclean what
about lady Mae I'm sorry Your Majesty
lady Mae is cling to so you will have
everyone have their cycles except the
one you want to sync with the Emperor
yes I have succeeded too many times
thank you thank you questions questions
you are you have to be at the microphone
you have to raise your hand on the
microphone because we are on c-span
cable television so I want you to
yes
if you could meet Madame Mao today and
she were still alive
what would you say to her that's a very
good question I probably would just have
tell her my story I think that she
probably would not have to be a Evo and
so in fear and scared and she would have
probably will be on a regret but you
know she if she had a see what I see cuz
I can see myself if I remain in China I
would never be a human being run today
I remember my shock first can see you
know television was I think 80 81 I had
a nine inch black white TV a whole
neighborhood was watching it it was
censored and we were supposed to watch a
American worker on demonstrating in
demonstrating in front of Chicago's City
Hall and I was shocked because they are
not the defect and they were better
clothes than that we did so just that I
opening experience just to so I think I
get a more you know experience in
education and then allow myself to be a
human being that would that would really
change the core of a of from she didn't
really have to waste her life to be so
evil
yes
first thank you so much for sharing in
Retta sale you you talked about your
family and your siblings and I'm
wondering if you could share with us
what became of your siblings and what
they're doing
thank you my siblings after I came to
the United States like every other
immigrants you want to help my family
but they all had the misfortune to be
rejected by the American consulate and
the reason for that was the immigration
immigrant tendency and that because I
was here and so eventually I after I
graduate I wanted to be a I want to go
into education so I wanted to be a
teacher and go back to China but my
father says no she says do you remember
you once denounced a teacher when you
were 11
she's a concern American spy is that
what you're doing that you you'll feel
bad and what you did that you want to
come back and do the same thing and the
don't you can you imagine our
relationship with America's very fragile
and someday your students would come
denounce you as Americans fine then you
gonna gap go into prison like your uncle
did and so I was guilty and besides my
father says you're coming back that
doesn't guarantee a visa for my sister
brother you see so after several tried
they all failed no luck so my brother
went to Japan and my sister went to
Australia and the other one to Singapore
and also the good thing is that we found
something about my parents my father
actually is here he comes to visit me
see ya job you remember you read Odelia
he tried to drag us alpha to watch the
moon and then eclipse in the law that
we're so Johnson we didn't wanted to and
today he got to he's working with the
ever planetarium
the director who wanted to do a show on
ancient Chinese astronomy and they
turned to working with him and it was a
great thing he gets her a history and
come true my mother who passed away two
years ago but we found out that done she
was a Christian so basically she raised
to me silently in a Christian way and I
remember it in a way it's uh it makes
sense because I bumped into her in one
of the nights doing the culture of when
she was on her knees and remember asking
what are you doing in the dark she
couldn't explain because she explained
to me I was ahead Aurelio record I would
report her and she'll be jailed but I
think it was my mother's the strength
that she always believed that maybe I I
benefit from her belief in spirit of the
question
thank you
do you have a sense of what the reaction
to your novels uh is in China
if there is one thank you for the
question I'm pronounced on the mountain
in China first of all how dare you to
even write about that evil woman and of
course you if you read the book you know
that all these information it's cost
translated back to the regime who you
come to think about you read the book
ect look at what this woman did she
makes a better leader damn mouth
so it's she is a dangerous subject today
and that there was a his documentary
shows about her all get cancelled by the
end and I dare to write about these
subjects it's it's a it's a it's still
taboo as do i I don't feel good about it
because I don't consider myself the best
writer I tell you a lot of great writers
in China and they it's such a terrible
thing that they they can't really the
half of the documents in English so they
are either self-censored I'll be
brainwashed and have no it's you live in
China you're just in this condition in
this environment
you just cannot overcome and when I when
you you became you're your own enemy
because you're so narrow-minded like I
was I truly believed that Americans were
evil and I when I saw that you know the
Twin Towers come down I knew exactly
what went through the mind of of the
terrorists because when you were telling
them in the or do you know that the
thing they watched we were training the
heroic thing to do is take the explosive
and the jumping to the American soldier
and the use here to the grand the movie
you know ultra coming back over the
smoke and your body ashes glorified gory
thing to do and and so it
great thing just to shoot me down and
now it's hardly don't get chest to do it
in America they do on the Internet the
way they do on the internet there's
somebody there to give me five stars and
they come up and they give it one star
they talk to all their friends they come
and give you one star to bring the book
down and I know the review they wrote I
know it's in Chinese isn't my kind of
English I recognize that I feel sorry
for them
and I feel that they the wonderful
things that I experienced in America and
even the classroom it's the that we
allow different view and you really you
feel free to make your own judgments
even my daughter she was educated that
way and it's such a fortunate thing and
then you have to know not everybody
around in the world gets to do that
so in China a quarter a quarter
population on earth is in this close to
lid we caused all the frauds under the
well I think the sky was just as big as
the ring well so that's how they see me
and I don't really mind I really think
that it's gonna take time and eventually
when they get the chance to learn what I
know and it's gonna be explosive
go ahead thank you
just based on what you were saying I
recently read a book it's called nine
commentaries on the Communist Party I
think it's a joke ping Gong chime down
are you familiar with that book 9
commentary Chuck Joe ping don't jump
down really yeah that I read it so it's
like a history of underground
yes it's an underground book that's
supposed to be circulating in China and
has caused supposedly like 8 million
people in the last year to withdraw from
the Communist Party oh no I don't think
it's a waste or it's it's it's the I
have friends a lot of friends they told
me it says you know I'm two things they
were safe
if somebody has a mental problem that
he's trying to join the Communist Party
that's question they think one thing
they say in China the second thing they
say you know I'm sorry I got a I got a I
gotta join the party because if I joined
the party I got all the benefits it's
like you have a retirement incentives
you join the party you get the first
they take cover their own people but
everybody knows all these things
circulating like releve Lea circulating
on the ground because it's their own
history I mean II strongly Chinese China
see you have a hundred thousand use
their history being erased and imagine
the rest of the country so read a
zillion I read underground copy it's
beautifully done because I wrote in
English but they translated it I know
the translator lifted fine translating
it because it's her or his life too so I
believed yes that the kind of book
existed but it's if they find out the
author they can arrest him arrest him
they imprison him I'm sure of that and
that they will not say that you have a
political crime you write that book they
will say you are dating the wrong guy
it's a female of it's a guy they say you
have either corrupted or you have other
problem your rapist last question